il a évoqué ils vont les termes sont
formels la complicité des manifestants
qui étaient dans la rue ce week-end
entre autres avec les casseurs qu'on a
vu le 1er mai est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est adapté
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
je n'ai cité des manifestants je pense
qu'il faut il faut là aussi c'est c'est
trop facile de sortir tel de telles
bulles phrase faut le remettre dans le
contexte on doit rencontrer tous dans
une société de la vigilance dans une
société et ses traits pour la sécurité
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que chacun peut participer
en identifiant en allant avertir en
prenant ses responsabilités quand vous
êtes hommes politiques pour faire en
sorte que demain il n'y a pas il n'y
avait pas la possibilité d'avoir ces
black blocks qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les manifestants et quand vous êtes à la
tempe licite et quand vous êtes un
manifestant vous même vous avez la
possibilité là aussi de participer
quand vous voyez des personnes à les
prévenir un tel goût d'amande et
concrètement dans ce cas pour moi c'est
cette société de vigilance c'est de dire
que là aussi la vie en société
c'est la vie on a tous et tous la
possibilité de participer à cet effort
collectif et s'agissant de la sécurité
s'agissant de la prévention on a toutes
et tous la possibilité d'agir là où nous
nous trouvons
quand vous êtes manifestants quand vous
êtes un élu local quand vous êtes
mandina sentir quand on lui avec en tête
de cortège le black box vous pouvez
effectivement allé avertir quand vous
voyez des lignes personne qui parce
qu'on connaît bien leurs techniques
ils arrivent et ils sont pas habillées
en black blocks et puis tout d'un coup
mais pour vous les identifier avez vous
travaillé forces de l'ordre lé prévient
défense lorsque s'alarmer travail des
forces de repérer aussi sais pas mais
bien entendu mais c'est absolument pas
ça que dit gérard collomb pense que il
ya bien un reproche qu'on ne peut pas
faire à gérard collomb c'est de ne pas
être fermes pour lutter sans relâche en
mettant tous les moyens de police
nécessaires pour faire en sorte que ces
individus ne puisse agir et pour faire
en sorte que tous ceux qui souhaitent
manifester puisse le faire dans le calme
en aucun cas gérard collomb dit que ce
n'est pas le boulot des forces de
l'ordre bien au contraire c'est le
boulot des forces de l'ordre après une
société de vigilance
moi je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
est tout à fait bien et justifiée
puisque la complicité en fait vous
déplorez là
si vite et des manifestants je déplore
rien je dis juste que lorsque la banque
de vigilance non je n'en je dis juste
que quand nous vivons en société nous
avons tous là où nous agissons là nous
vivons en fonction de nos métiers de nos
fonctions nous avons tous la possibilité
de participer à notre vie en société il
ya une image qui a marqué les esprits
lors de la marée humaine qui était
annoncé samedi 16 de d'emmanuel macron
dans un uniforme nazi comment est ce que
vous avez reçu cette image mais tu as
grandi dans les rues ces images alors
que ce soit celle là où où que ce soit
celle où nous voyons emmanuel macron son
effigie brûlés sont totalement
inqualifiable et insupportable mais je
pense que là aussi dans les manifestants
vous avez deux types de manifestants
vous avez ceux qui revendiquent qui
portent des propositions qui sont en
désaccord mais qui essaye de faire
avancer le débat
et puis vous en avez d'autres qui ont
des propos des propos que moi je trouve
antidémocratique
des propos qui ne vise qu'à une chose
c'est de refaire le match c'est à dire
de revenir sur les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle
la seule et vraie marée populaire pour
reprendre le terme de ce week-end c'est
l'élection présidentielle moi quand
j'entends un jean luc mélenchon
mélenchon appeler une révolution
populaire
un front populaire aussi et oui mais je
prends ce terme de révolution
je dis à jean luc mélenchon mais le soir
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle les français n'ont pas
choisi votre programme est donc arrêté
de refaire le match
à chaque fois respecter le vote des
français
on peut être contre hull soyons contre
de manière constructive avec des
propositions et non pas dans ses
postures parce que quand il s'agit
d'être démocrate il faut l'être
tous les jours on n'est pas démocrate
quand ça nous arrange parce que le vote
des français est allé dans son sens je
sais